former attorney general has become the
latest conservative mp to call for the
prime minister to go let's get more on
this straight away live to our political
correspondent ali fortescue all of
course in the wake of sue gray's damning
report ali
yes that's right what we've seen the
last few days is a trickle of letters
being sent to segrean brady the chairman
of the 1922 committee it takes 52
letters for a vote of no confidence to
be triggered and the latest letter to go
in today
is from jeremy wright this brings a
total now to 25 letters according to our
spreadsheet he is a former cabinet
minister uh former culture secretary
i'll just read you um so it's
interesting he posted this on his
website since though his statement has
been deleted from his website but um it
did say before it was deleted it now
seems to me that the prime minister
remaining in office will hinder those
crucial objectives i have therefore with
regret concluded that the pr for the
good of this future
of this and future government sorry the
prime minister should resign so making
it clear um that he thinks the prime
minister should resign therefore we
think he probably has sent his letter
into the 1922 committee and he had been
someone like many others who had been on
the fence hadn't confirmed whether or
not they wanted to see the prime
minister go and we know that 35 mps
are publicly questioning the prime
minister and of course that is a number
of people that are publicly speaking out
we know
that in reality more mps could have sent
their letters into the committee
remember when therese may face a vote of
no confidence the number of publicly
declared letter was actually half that
um that we're really in so the numbers
couldn't be quite what they see
seem but of course this is um this comes
after an extraordinary week where we had
the full sue gray report the damning
detail and i think speaking to mps last
week the the sense you got was that
some thought thought that the details in
particular things like um details about
wine on the wall details of treatment of
cleaners and staff details of a person
being sick at one of the events that
happened in downing street i think they
all found it really embarrassing and i
think some weren't quite happy with the
prime minister's response they didn't
quite think he was contrite enough they
think that this is a culture that has
started
from the top and that is why we are
seeing those letters slowly being handed
in but i think people have really
wrestled with themselves over the
weekend i was speaking to one mp that
handed in their letter over the weekend
who said it was a really difficult
decision they they sent a a letter out
to constituents they didn't really want
to make a big fuss of it but mps are
unhappy and that is why we are seeing
more letters being handed in we of
course not at that threshold yet of 54.
remember we did have um a huge package
of support being announced just last
week the day after the sue grey report
um when the transfer announced 15
billion hounds pounds to help people
with the cost of living the government
of course want to shift the focus onto
their domestic agenda but we are seeing
the pool of mps unhappy with the prime
minister growing by the day and that i
think will be very concerning for
downing street
ali many thanks indeed bringing us uh up
to date there on our breaking news you
can see at the bottom of your screen
jeremy wright uh former attorney general
general and culture secretary becoming
the latest conservative mp uh to call on
boris johnson to go well if you scan the
qr code
on your screen right now you can follow
all of today's political events live on
the sky news politics hub including sky
news very own producer tom larkin's list
larkin's list also known as tom's tally
that catalogues the tory mps that have
spoken out recently
against the prime minister and that
spreadsheet is now growing isn't it all
on the sky news app and website